well officially now what is the deal
with you it rose okay so right now we
have parted ways and you know with a
heavy heart and I'm you know I headed
back to San Diego
you know with the ring I had bought that
ring I met Rose on on Facebook fell in
love bought a ring and TLC found out
about it and next thing you know I'm on
this show so uh yeah it's been a fun
ride um we just weren't we wanted
different things
you know Rose wanted what she wanted and
I wanted what I wanted and it just
didn't we weren't in alignment we didn't
want did you know upfront what she
wanted that and that it didn't jive with
what you wanted I sorta did like the the
the fact that you know I told her from
the beginning I have a muffin I I have
enough love in my heart for her and
Prince I knew that that was a package
deal and she had slightly mentioned that
she wanted a baby girl someday and that
was about it that's all we ever talked
about kids it was a one-time
conversation probably you know in the
beginning of when we met and I honestly
kind of forgot about it and then the the
whole height Saint thing that was kind
of you know silly I eat when I got back
from San Diego cuz excuse me when I got
back from the Philippines the first
thing I did is I went and got tested you
know for STD and I was clean which I
knew I was but they also measured me and
the girl goes okay you know you're
50-year you're five feet and a half an
inch with shoes on so I'm actually in
reality I'm five foot so I don't know if
I grew you know three inches or I just
you know misrepresented my height so you
kind of made a big deal about that I
think it really did piss her off when I
asked her to take the STD test and
consequently when I got back I did you
know I I talked to my daughter about
that and she's like well um you know if
you would have got the test first and
then went down there and said hey Rose
look I took the test you know when you
take a test that's what I should have
done obviously I screwed that up so yeah
do you feel like you
it all up you know what no I'll tell you
why because I this morning I got like 37
marriage proposals online and and the
cool thing is I accepted every one of
them so are you are you done with this
kind of thing now like obviously are you
just giving Rose some space or are you
now moving on officially you know what
I'm you know we it's the breakup is so
fresh so I'm going to you know keep keep
an open mind you know who knows you know
she's somebody that I loved very very
much despite what you hear on mine I
didn't um you know people are saying
online they're kind of trashing me
saying that you just went on the show to
be famous you know first of all I didn't
even know about the show before I bought
my ticket that's number one and number
two I think I tell people look name one
thing
name one thing I did on the show that
made myself look good because I can't
think of one because a lot of people
were saying that when they when Jeffrey
said that you know there's certain
people that were on the show for a
platform and that maybe they weren't
they're looking for love a lot of people
say that he was talking about you yeah
you know that poor guy I feel sorry for
him as well as baby Lisa and and Darcy I
mean they're you know I'm actually
shocked you know it at you know not so
much at Joffrey or Lisa but with Darcy I
mean she should know better that you
read stuff online and then she throws
that in my face and I come on
that's just borderline delusional it
means it's it's not you know some of the
things that people say are just so far
just detached from reality it's not even
funny
and I don't know you know we you know
we're you know Jeffrey you know Joffrey
rather came up with right you know
somehow I was I was dancing on pool
tables 12 years ago and I have the
pictures to prove it in a nacho libre
costume well today I'm doing about 30 to
40 cameos a day in my Nacho Libre
costume it's actually the same costume
that I had know 12 years ago and now I'm
making money I'm just I'm having fun
with it you know I really am this you
know I didn't go on the show to be
famous
actually when thee when the show first
broke when they started to do the
teasers in January we filmed way back in
August so I couldn't talk about the show
for months and when the first teaser
came out with me on my Vespa I'm like oh
my God look you know this is really fun
you know everybody's gonna know who I am
and then all of the hates like at 150
miles an hour like you know you know I
can't wait till next season you know
where's your neck I'm like oh my god
everything that my daughter and my mom
warned me about you know don't do this
it's not a good idea
started to happen so I kind of you know
pull back into my hole and like okay
this is not good I'm gonna lose my job I
just literally I thought I I really
screwed my life at that point and the
publicist from TLC is like okay first of
all don't read stop don't go online just
stay away from it leave it alone well
then people started to defend me like
you know hey don't count this guy out
and then then there an article came out
you know this is you know I didn't write
this I didn't you know I basically
repeated it but somebody wrote an
article he's the most authentic reality
star in TLC history those aren't my
words and I repeated that once
potentially getting back in the game
I'm sure you've watched yourself a lot
with some of the ways that you tackle
difficult conversations whether it be
about bad breath or STDs moving forward
moving forward what have you learned
about yourself and how you talk to
people when it comes to a new woman
potentially in your life finding love
what are you doing differently this time
around well first of all I am gonna
listen to my daughter that's number one
and I'm also going to you know
definitely be more tactful it's been a
while since I've been in in a
relationship and you know I wasn't
trying to be offensive in any way and I
and I have never ever said you know
anything negative nor will I ever about
rose I have the utmost amount of respect
for her but I was literally very very
concerned with you know that with her
hygiene and I obviously didn't handle
that in the right way I thought kind of
balancing the lingerie with the
toothpaste was a was a good idea okay
that backfired
you know in the biggest way possible and
if you go online to look at all the
memes that's the proof and then as far
as the STD like I said my daughter's
like dad come on you know hindsight's
20/20 next time you know you should have
got the test so that was really unfair
you know lying about my height and like
um you know one thing I that I'm not
very proud of is I did want I came clean
but I didn't want to tell rose I didn't
want more kids I can't I can't afford it
and instead of being honest with her
because I was afraid if I was that I
would lose her like she would she would
break up with me so I I hid that from
her and that was wrong and I don't
recommend that so what I've learned is
this okay just be honest and if they're
gonna run they're gonna run and this
this surreal experience
it cost me you know I don't know you
know three to four months of my life and
about five thousand dollars but you know
what I'm ready to define love again and
that's the best gift that Rose gave me
as I'm ready to fall in love I'm not
afraid anymore amazing if she calls you
tomorrow and says it made a huge mistake
I want you back in my life forever do
you say yes I would approach with
caution but um yeah I'm still look I'm
still hurt you know I'm I'm sad that it
didn't work out so I I feel you know
that sense of failure that that flight
home man sucked it was you know 23 hours
or yeah 24 hours actually one hour more
you know fine back with no Malbec no
rose and and the ring it just it was a
it was a heart punch it was it didn't
feel good it was a gut punch not a hard
punch we got it listen you know we we
love you up here you got a lot of fans
in Canada brother so take care good luck
and you know everybody's still rooting
for you okay and one more time it's Ross
right yeah ah Rosie listen brother
listen just I want to give the biggest
shout out the biggest hard punch the
biggest Halik to everybody in Canada you
guys you guys have given me so much love
you guys are ney never- I don't hear one
negative thing out of Canada so I just
want to tell
you from the bottom of my heart that I
love you God bless you and two big
things right
love yourself okay and laugh at yourself
always